[Music]
I don't know if you know this but here
at the Pete home show we love video
games I'm a big video game guy but
nowadays I find it's a little
overwhelming there's so many to choose
from that it's kind of hard to know
which ones to pick so we wanted to shine
a spotlight on some of the Lesser known
favorite video games here at the pet
home show because I don't know if you
know this we are aware of all the
games so first off let's see what we
have here we have uh Mormon combat yeah
okay
okay Mormon
combat convert
him extra funny cuz I look Mormon is
that is that why that's playing so
well uh from the people at Nintendo we
have Kirby what the am
I uh in the Lego Family of games we have
Lego Human Centipede that's going
to I mean if they fit together they
wanted us to do that
right and finally Dr Mario gyno
[Laughter]
Edition what is Luigi doing
now I help her you sa her the princess
you do this for me
w